dalida en chips et 30 ans de carrière
2000 chansons 140 millions d'albums
vendus dans le monde premier obtenir un
disque d'or disque de platine disque de
diamant première chanteuse à voir son
image sur une pochette de disque et donc
les sept secrets on va les passer aussi
son strabisme par exemple qui a fait sa
légende comme laquelle elle était
tellement imité son strabisme il était
dû à quoi madame il était dit ou fait
que très jeune quand elle était encore
bébé vous savez il vivait en egypte nous
a et donc l'eau là-bas contient quelque
chose il a une maladie des yeux mais non
oui et c'est comme ça qu'elle a eu tout
bébé et que le médecin un mauvais
médecin a dit il faut lui bander les
yeux pendant 40 jours qu'elle reste dans
l'obscurité la plus totale pendant 40
jours et comme ça ça va s'arranger et
évidemment elle ne supportait très mal
elle était vraiment tout petit son père
pietro qui était premier violon à
l'opéra du caire essayez qu'il adorait
essayait de heaven et lui jouer du
violon etc pour essayer de la distraire
parce qu'elle essayait tout le temps
d'arracher le bandeau qu'évidemment elle
ne supportait pas et on lui remettait
toujours le bandeau est en fait donc ça
a été le début si vous voulez d'une
espèce de relation avec l'obscurité
qu'elle a eu comme ça c'est un complexe
toute sa vie ça oui parce que quand on a
enlevé le bandeau au bout de 40 jours en
fait il y avait un strabisme puisque il
y avait un tout petit coin où elle
réussissait à avoir un peu de lumière au
coin du bandeau là et donc elle essayait
désespérément de regarder ce petit coin
de lumière et donc en fait ça a été une
catastrophe alors il ya eu opérations
sur opérationnelle cette non cette
opération est dit piaf avait la main
porter des lunettes aussi non à un
moment donné elle a porté des lunettes
alors c'était des grosses lunettes
comment faisait à l'époque avec des vers
et
depuis
leur double folin et mais en même temps
c'est cette fragilité sous complexe qui
sera sa force mais exactement comment
fait elle a répondu à cette petite
annonce comme fait partie des artistes
qui ont vraiment commencé leur carrière
par une petite annonce ce soit patrick
bruel françoise hardy sophie marceau et
dalida on oublie de le dire parce que
c'est en répondant à une petite annonce
qu'elle s'inscrit au concours de miss
egypte
non à partir de là
me sandrine bisson d'une même pièce et
miss absolument la première dauphine
absolument et puis ça la mènera bien sûr
après à la fameuse miss egypte a été
élue miss egypte avec l'oeil avec lost
rabbit et où elle se force un certain
regard moi le mal avait expliqué un jour
pour pour justement avoir cette forme
d'élégance de discrétion et en même
temps être la plus belle est assez
formidable et lorsque je ne savais pas
mais tout le monde avait l'air de le
savoir elle a eu une histoire d'amour
avec françois mitterrand et françois
mitterrand lui avait dit je veux que ça
ne se sache jamais mais c'était à quel
moment c'était avant mazarine c'est
après il était déjà l'elysée set et
quand c'était quoi c'est ça a commencé
avant qu'il soit élu et ça a continué
parce que ça continue sur presque dix
ans un oui mais mitch a pas que du nom
il se voyait pas forcément tout le temps
en fait elle n'était pas amoureuse de
lui mais l'admirais profondément bien
sûr eric leman bien sûr il a été fasciné
par le personnage est donc alors c'était
assez drôle parce que il l'appelait et
il y avait une phrase qui toujours la
même
j'aimerais bien manger des fruits de mer
et donc livenation et non quatre sources
et la dia plus chic que braz
cl rue des champs d'accord il ya un côté
onana c'est en fait ça s'est arrêté
vraiment parce que bon elle n'était pas
amoureuse bien sûr ça s'est arrêté
vraiment quand elle a rencontré richard
chanfray il a été très dynamique aux
joueurs et là elle lui a dit ben non
maintenant c'est terminé et fabien
savoir c'est hallucinant relation des
qu'alain delon également oui alors il
est sidérant c'était connu d'abord à
paris quand tu es dalida arrive à paris
à 25 décembre 54 et de loin en ménage et
une petit 16h10
non il était il habitait le même hôtel
67 rue de ponthieu à paris après quand
ils ont commencé à gagner un peu tout et
ils sont ils ont déménagé ensemble
prendre une chambre de bonne rue jean
mermoz dans le même quartier du 8eme
arrondissement donc ils ont pas arrêté
de se voir jusque là ils étaient
simplement amis et leur liaison s'est
passé à rome puisque alain delon allait
tourner un film en italie donc et puis
dalida était en tournée italienne ce qui
est une des rares artistes on oublie de
le rappeler c'est mondiale d'acier bien
sûr c'est la première artiste
dial c'est à dire donc être cette espèce
de gloire elle chantait dans tous les
pays quand vous dites à l'enregistrer
400 chansons en france ben y en a eu
deux sens rien qu'en italien 200 en
japonais anglais allemand enfin
ukrainiens russes enfin elle a chanté
pratiquement dans toutes les langues
c'était très rare donc elle était
demandée dans tous les pays la durée
commentary leur liaison sentimentale et
lieux le temps du tournage justement des
films de visconti et madame ans et le
départ n'était pas amoureuse elle n'a
pas été à la part non mais je pense
qu'elle l'admirais je pense à dalida
elle aimait les hommes toujours un peu
le même type d'homme comme sabre un peu
toujours à zéro aucune chance quand on
sait que le ch tis le sosie de alain
delon anthony delon était en couple avec
la jeune femme qui a incarné davy
d'accord d'accord d'accord une petite
question puisqu'on parle côté coeur moi
ça m'a toujours intrigué mike brant il
était camille dalida et non mike brant
où ils ont une relation ils ont une
relation qui était même très secrète bah
voilà sont rencontrés au festival de
venise de la chanson et coquine c'est en
1969 elle tombe d'admiration de marie
montre moi j'ai vu une fois dans la
glace était une fois un ses concerts en
74 il avait la beauté du diable et oui
inquiétant de beauté est vraiment et
elle est tombée tout de suite amoureuse
de lui ella ella ils ont une liaison
évidemment qui a été très important elle
a mis en première partie de ses concerts
le rsa apa santé oms
et puis d'ailleurs il ya une émission
une archive on television chemist oui
chérie shell drucker indien au rendez
vous du dimanche quand il chante pas
ensemble lui chante à côté d'elle dalida
est assise à côté de michel drucker sur
le canapé elle lui jette des regards et
lui aussi n'ose pas il ne veut pas se
regarder vous savez quand les gens
couchent ensemble en télévision ça se
voit gbagbo oui à raison
et je peux vous dire que oui vrai qu'il
a qui couche avec qui aurait sa valeur
on en attendait
très embêté mais vous savez quand vous
avez deux personnes qui couchent
ensemble dans la vie si les visions
semble je peux vous dire j'ai vérifié 50
fois non isolée gens de soi se regardent
et se parler parce qu'elle sur arte est
une forme d'intimité et cette émission
de drucker vous voyez dalida qui est à
côté de mike brant elle n'ose pas
regarder lui non plus on sent qu'il joue
un personnage différent alors que
secrètement ce avec finalement il y
avait une vraie liaison alors la fameuse
chanson pas pour nous la plus célèbre il
venait d'avoir 18 ans
bref il paraît que sa femme
[Musique]
non
et paraît que ça parle d'un drame cette
chanson je ne crie pas parce qu'elle se
bat c'est quoi ce drame
elle a été amoureuse d'un jeune italien
luigi tenco après laffaire kenko après
laffaire tenco donc tenco n'était pas
vraiment plus jeunes c'est lucho qui
était plus jeune et elle a rencontré ce
lucho lors d'une émission de télévision
après la mort de tant qu il était fan de
telco et ils ont eu une histoire
ensemble et elle veut dire à paris
d'ailleurs un pardon l'a fait venir pour
le noël elle a fait venir pour noël à
paris où c'est un peu choqué le reste de
la famille qui l'avait il avait 16 ans
17 ans à peine on sait comment se feront
surtout ça il à lui raconter la frère de
lucho oui ça c'est quand même un peu sur
ces sud accord et puis en fait c'est pas
elle qui l'a fait venir il est venu pour
noël avec ses valises brusquement il a
sonné à la porte on est la famille ne
l'attendait pas du tout vous savez c'est
navale familles italiennes ou vraiment
tout le monde est là pour les fêtes etc
et c'est vraiment intime et là il ya ce
jeune homme qui débarque alors il
ressemblait un peu atenco est bon ce qui
a été un peu terrible c'est qu'elle est
tombée enceinte deux options absolument
et que lucho était tout il était fou
d'elle donc elle elle plus ou moins elle
financer un peu ses études il faisait
des études de philo il était très pauvre
et il ya des lettres très émouvante que
j'ai lu dans lesquelles il dit ben voila
j'ai trouvé les livres d'occasion
c'était pas cher et c'est parce qu'il
voulait pas être à ses crochets et elle
est tombée enceinte de lucho lucho
voulait absolument cette enfant mais la
pensée c'est pas possible c'est une
histoire qui ne durera pas apportées et
elle a avorté et qu'enfin on ait pris
leur parti en italie tandis que rim sur
la wii c'est lors de cette coupe pour
les gens qui nous regardent et qui ne
savent pas forcément comptoir de tenkoto
caussade et son deuxième grand amour il
s'est suicidé le soir d'après steve à la
san remo il a perdu où elle a gagné et
elle l'a retrouvé mort par la chambre le
soir voilà ce que c'est là on commence à
entrer dans la partie la plus globaux et
de celle de cette femme tout ce qui
effectivement c'est trois maris trois
suicides plus que ça oui mais moi je
souhaitais pas dalida mois qu'il est un
peu connu c'est à dire que c'est une
faille qui était joyeuse voilà et mais
là il y aller mais l'amour les mets
vraiment les hommes et c'était pas du
tout aujourd'hui le psychodrame qu'on
veut en faire souvent malheureusement je
trouve alors qu'à la maison saint gillis
et
pesant mais on peut souffrir et être
souriant et solaire en fait c'est ça je
pense que c'est un paradoxe mer et les
champs suivants qui se suicide sont des
joyaux des toujours les clous dans les
yeux tristes près souvent cci à gaza il
ya toute cette part d'ombré comme ça
dans les personnages alors c'est vrai
que luigi tenco s'est suicidé dans
janvier 67 on a eu lucien morisse ou ben
oui voici une liste qui a été fabriqué
les lensois semblent repartis il qu'on
en a eu évidemment aussi on peut
rajouter mike brant parce que dans la
première qui arrive au chevet de mike
brant dalida le 22 octobre 74 après
s'être suicidé la maman de mike brant ne
vient pas tout de suite ces dalida qui a
la première il avait la fascination de
la mort tous les deux et puis le dernier
en juillet 83 c'est richard chanfray qu
est le fait le soi-disant nom de saint
germain qui avait le don de transfert
transformer le plomb en or en art ou
comme au xviiie siècle le vrai conte de
saint germain qui avait 17 milan
souhaite soit disant mais il faut savoir
que les arthurs ajoute le sien ça fait 5
c'est quand même une vie compliquée mais
pardon des tous réussis ouais mais en
même temps les artistes adorent ce genre
de personnage comme richard et geoffrey
c'est à dire c'est elle veut l'entendre
qu'ils ont envie dans turbo riant oui
j'ai une question pour madame parce
qu'on parle de de dalida comme une
personne joyeuse trees sinistre moi j'ai
lu et entendu relativement souvent que
c'était quelqu'un qui avait un lien avec
le paranormal ou en tout cas avec le
mystérieux assez importants notamment
qu'elle a déjà été en retraite
chamanique à une ou à plusieurs reprises
donc voir ce que vous avez à dire là
dessus elle avait effectivement elle est
là elle est allée plusieurs fois mais ça
c'était c'était la période arnaud
desjardins n'est ce pas où elle a eu une
liaison avec un os desjardins et il
avait un soin mis en inde et elle est
allée plusieurs fois l'était
effectivement j'ai vu la correspondance
d'ailleurs avec cet homme et en plus des
jardins voulait l'épouser et qu'elle a
mais qu'elle arrête de chanter et c'est
le swami qui a dit mais il n'est pas
question il a voulu entendre un disque
et quand il a entendu il a dit non votre
destin c'est de chanter il sera question
d'arrêter de chanter et a été très
positif en fait pour elle c'est elle et
lui ces lettres d'un forage il essayait
vraiment de l'aider de l'encourager et
le dernier mot fabien certains dernier
mot pardon parce qu'il faut qu'on avance
un petit peu mais c'est passionnant
dalida on aurait pu faire tout terrain
le suicide dernier son fichier dlc c'est
quand une accumulation la dénomination
lt montmartre sa maison de montmartre
elle devait elle devait voir dans la
soirée un nouvel homme dans sa vie
françois gaudy et puis et puis il a
décommandé alors c'est une accumulation
de choses bien sûr le physique savez la
difficulté de dalida c'étaient les
miroirs ouais c'est à dire compte pour
beaucoup de femmes aussi et célèbre
surtout c'est à dire c'est de se voir
quand on a eu cette évolution on a été
élu pour sa beauté pour huer et c'est
quand vous avez que 54 ans parce que
c'est que 54 ans la date de sa
disparition
mais pour elle c'était un drame chaque
jour chaque miroir il ya eu ça il ya eu
cette espèce de souffrance aussi avec
ceux strabisme sur le puits le dernier
rendez vous puisque les hommes étaient
moins à ses pieds malheureusement bien
sûr et je pense que tout ça c'est alors
qu'elle était au zénith du succès et il
faut saluer dans sa mémoire de délia
faut saluer son frère orlando parce que
sans orlando oui y'a pas eu dalida celle
que tout le monde connaît avec les shows
télé et c est juste rapidement pour les
fans de dalida et un biopic de ardisson
le 2 mai sur france 3 ou en fait elle va
raconter sa propre histoire ça va être
fascinant c'est fait avec taking
pictures c'est un interview que j'ai eu
la possibilité de voir hier soir et
c'est captivant que les fans de dalida
et non mon frère tu écriras mémoire aux
éditions plon voilà deux catherine rioux
inquiéter avec tous merci beaucoup
catherine et fabien comme d'habitude
c'est formidable
[Applaudissements]